[Música]
Nicaragua contempla suspender sus
relaciones con el Vaticano así lo indicó
el Ministerio de exteriores
nicaragüenses después de que el Papa
Francisco calificara al gobierno del
presidente Daniel Ortega como una
dictadura
los clientes del silicon podrán acceder
a todo su dinero A partir de este lunes
así lo declararon los reguladores
estadounidenses que tomaron una serie de
medidas de emergencia para evitar una
crisis bancaria
ocho personas murieron en las costas de
San Diego California en medio de una
aparente caso de tráfico de migrantes se
cree que los dos botes pesqueros en los
que se transportaban se volcaron la
noche del sábado a causa de las
condiciones climáticas que vive el
estado
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en France 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Nicaragua que plantea suspender las
relaciones diplomáticas con el Vaticano
asilo comunicó la cancillería a través
de un comunicado el anuncio se conoce
dos días después de una entrevista que
el papá Francisco concedió al medio
digital infobae y en la que calificó al
gobierno de Daniel Ortega como una
dictadura al tiempo que criticó la
condena contra el obispo nicaragüense
Rolando Alves lluís Muñoz tiene más
detalles
Nicaragua y el Vaticano en crisis
primeras informaciones aseguraban que el
gobierno de Daniel Ortega había roto sus
relaciones diplomáticas con la santa
sede desde el Ministerio de exteriores
nicaragüense lo calificaron de noticia
falsa y precisaron el gobierno de
Reconciliación y unidad nacional de
nuestra Nicaragua bendita y siempre
libre precisa que entre el estado
Vaticano y la República de Nicaragua se
ha planteado una suspensión de las
relaciones diplomáticas
pese a ser la institución con mayor
aprobación del país la Iglesia Católica
está siendo perseguida por el gobierno
de Ortega una escena de eclesiásticos
llegaron a ser apresados otros han sido
desterrados y la semana santa prohibida
entre los 222 excarcelados políticos
expulsados a Estados Unidos no estuvo
monseñor Rolando Álvarez quien se negó a
viajar con el resto le condenaron a 26
años de cárcel esto ha enfadado al Papa
Francisco
yo ahí con mucho respeto
no me queda otra que pensar en un
desequilibrio
de la persona que dirige
fuera de lo que estamos viviendo es como
si fuera a traer
de dictaduras
del 17 comunistas o hitlerianas del 35
están las aquí las mismas
tipo de dictaduras
groseras
días antes Ortega había dicho que los
curas los obispos y los papás son una
mafia mientras que hace un año Nicaragua
ya había expulsado al nuncio papal
Valdemar estánislav
después de la histórica quiebra del
silicon el viernes pasado el gobierno de
Estados Unidos intervino para evitar una
posible crisis bancaria la secretaria
del tesoro Yanet Allen junto al
presidente de la reserva federal y el
presidente de la corporación Federal de
seguros de depósitos anunciaron que
todos los clientes de auxilio podrán
acceder a su dinero A partir de este
lunes la medida pretende evitar que se
genere un contagio en otros bancos
pequeños y por ello los reguladores
decidieron también cerrar signature Bank
con sede en Nueva York se espera que el
presidente Joe biden se dirija a la
nación este lunes para dar un parte de
tranquilidad sobre el sistema bancario
previamente hablamos con Federico Alves
él es economista y ex analista de riesgo
en la bolsa de valores quien nos explicó
Cómo se produjo esta situación
el negocio bancario es un negocio muy
delicado porque los bancos están
presionados para poner todos sus capital
flotante en producir algo no lo pueden
tener el presupuesto en cuentas sin sin
rendimiento y después de muchos años con
una tasa de interés nega todos los
bancos tienen una cantidad de su capital
invertido en bonos de la tesorería
norteamericana Qué pasó que los
intereses subieron de una manera
violenta inesperada y como como todo el
mundo sabe cuando uno tiene un Bono y
los intereses que paga el bono por
ejemplo es de 2% y hartas en tres sube
al 6% el precio de ese Bono como como el
como capital financiero cae
dramáticamente entonces este banco tenía
el 70% de todo su su dinero su capital
invertido en bonos Y tuvo pérdidas que
por supuesto lo hacían inviable y además
hubo una corrida sobre el banco porque
un millonario amigo del presidente Trump
llamó a todas las empresas que él
controlaba y las de sus amigos y les
pidió que retiraran dinero del banco
Entonces como todo el mundo sabe también
los bancos cuando hay un una una
retirada masiva de dinero pues no pueden
afrontarlo porque ellos tienen papeles
que tienen que transformar en Cash en el
fondo esto es un error no solo del banco
sino de la secretaría del tesoro es un
error este de esta administración que
tiene que corregirlo porque el papel
fundamental del presidente biden y del
de la secretaría del tesoro y la fe de
Resort es justamente mantener la solidez
del sistema bancario y en esto han
fallado
cambiamos de tema y seguimos en Estados
Unidos en California ocho personas
murieron cerca de las costas de San
Diego luego de que dos embarcaciones
pesqueras presuntamente utilizadas para
el tráfico de migrantes naufragarán
producto de las dificultades climáticas
las autoridades informaron que alrededor
de 23 personas iban en los barcos pero
los sobrevivientes se dieron a la fuga
para no ser detenidos
una de las peores tragedias de
contrabando marítimo en California así
calificó el jefe de bomberos al
naufragio de dos embarcaciones pesqueras
utilizadas para trasladar migrantes y
que dejaron ocho personas muertas los
rescatistas no pudieron identificar la
procedencia de las víctimas pero
aseguraron que se trata de adultos esto
es parte de un esfuerzo de una
organización criminal transnacional para
contrabandear personas a los Estados
Unidos estas personas a menudo son
objeto de trata laboral y sexual cuando
llegan
el jefe de salvavidas de San Diego
agregó que alrededor de 23 personas iban
en los botes los cuales volcaron cerca
de la orilla como consecuencia de las
dificultades climáticas que experimenta
la región
los sobrevivientes se dieron a la fuga
según los funcionarios costeros en las
playas de San Diego cercanas a las del
estado mexicano de Tijuana los
accidentes son materia frecuente
tendría que buscar los números exactos
pero hemos tenido un par de cientos de
eventos este año fiscal está en
consonancia con los últimos años
Fiscales por lo general este año hubo
alrededor de 300 eventos marítimos pero
Eso incluye nadadores pangas y
embarcaciones de recreo
en San Diego suceden diversos accidentes
de personas que buscan llegar a Estados
Unidos tanto nadando como en botes
precarios pero este episodio es de los
más graves que se han registrado en
México 10 personas murieron y cinco
resultaron heridas producto de un ataque
armado en el municipio de Apaseo del
grande estado de Guanajuato los hechos
ocurrieron la noche del sábado cuando un
grupo de hombres se rompió en el
establecimiento y abrió fuego contra los
clientes y empleados la guardia nacional
la policía y equipos forenses realizan
operativos en esta zona de un estado que
se ha convertido en el más sangriento
del país a causa de la guerra entre los
carteles de la droga
en Colombia la propuesta de paz total
del presidente Gustavo Petro es vista
con buenos ojos por parte de uno de los
actores del conflicto las disidencias de
la guerrilla de las FARC que parecen
confiar en la oferta del actual
mandatario en los municipios olvidados
históricamente por el estado como el
charco de nariño sus habitantes guardan
la esperanza de que el proyecto se pueda
lograr
atrincherados en medio de la selva
colombiana disidentes de la guerrilla de
las FARC parecen creer en la nueva
propuesta de paz total del presidente
izquierdista Gustavo Petro tenemos un
gobierno
progresista que nos inspira confianza
creemos de que de que de pronto
con él podemos llegar a hacer acuerdos
que favorezcan al pueblo colombiano
estos guerrilleros decidieron no firmar
con el gobierno de ese entonces el
acuerdo de paz de 2016 cuando se
desmovilizaron gran parte de las fuerzas
armadas revolucionarias de Colombia
otros regresaron a las armas a pesar de
suscribir El pacto al llegar Petro el
poder se abrió una nueva puerta para que
finalmente haya un alto al fuego en el
pueblo del Charco de nariño un lugar
históricamente olvidado por el estado
hay esperanzas de que resulte el nuevo
acuerdo como ya estoy muy esperanzado
con el proyecto de paz total porque nos
va a garantizar de que la
institucionalidad pueda llegar aquí a
nuestro territorio según el Instituto
para el desarrollo y la paz y de paz el
65% de la población urbana y rural del
Charco ha sido objeto de desplazamiento
forzado pero la gente está esperando
oportunidades de una vida en paz no de
que se de que se estabilice una
situación de no violencia que se
organicen bien las actividades de
educación de Justicia
desde una vida de presencia del Estado
social de derecho con oportunidades de
ingreso para la gente si bien las
negociaciones han empezado con la
guerrilla del eln el proyecto de paz
total También incluye a los grupos
armados como el clan del Golfo y otras
bandas de narcotraficantes un camino que
podría ser arduo para el gobierno Petro
hasta que este informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]